all right if you've never seen hatred
mail before hatred mail is when a
professional voice-over artist does
interpretive readings of the hatred mail
I receive quick reminder about hatred
mail because the government that is
supposedly totally inept is the same
government that can pull off a
conspiracy that'll blow your mind
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom and let's get directly
directly into this week's hatred mail
which is riddled of course with
anti-semitism but also simple
misunderstandings about the nature of
reality around us David Pakman is a
typical Jew he smearing white people as
the problem again David shill for the
Jew ku Hackman hey David your psychology
isn't working playing the good Jew isn't
going to stop the inevitable oh and by
the way the stock market is up well over
twenty seven thousand points that's the
real is real so listen the UH the stock
market is not up more than twenty seven
thousand points it is true that the Dow
Jones has surpassed the twenty seven
thousand level but the stock market is
not up twenty seven thousand points
clearly someone who is very eager to
spout talking points that they heard
sort of but don't really understand but
you've got to understand the talking
points if you want to do a good job of
parroting them also smearing white
people what are you talking about the
david packard shows smearing white
people i think it would be good to
re-review some of our material you must
have a mistake mistaken for some other
show remember that the best way to fight
hatred ism is to use the coupon code
hate reott forty whenever you sign up
for a membership at join pakman.com you
save 40 percent the hatreds cry because
their hate messages are just
impotence they are unable to make any
headway that code is spelled h eighty
our iot
for zero